Barbara silver Horowitz barnard college
teachers college goodell be Horowitz
Columbia College Columbia Law School I
am very appreciative of my education of
convict i was in columbia law school I
started at Bonnard at the age of 16 a
very unsophisticated woman I say now
then I would have said girl might I add
I met g'day lat Bonnard he came to check
out the new women that Bonnard at a tea
dance they used to be held in the James
room bonnard hall they were samovars
with tea and cookies it was four o'clock
tee time right and they and i think the
the women appointed took turns serving
the tea it was a whole different world
because it was all women I had come from
a cup huge coed high school and coming
to a small college of just women was
wonderful because the women did
everything still has its own newspaper
still has its own student council still
has a faculty that is more than fifty
percent female it still has role models
for women that can use this and our
children also are philanthropists I
always say lease ads an innocent young
lady to bonnard who just matured and
became involved in so many things my son
didn't have any sense at all he went to
some boarding school in Cambridge as
opposed to going to Columbia where he
was admitted but he did up the good
sense to go to a good law school so no I
I must say I for me were very proud of
our children wherever they went to
school
I want to encourage other women of
ability to choose bonnard and therefore
established a scholarship which is
called Centennial scholars we didn't
want to put anyone's name on it Barnabas
I said I have been a trusted you I was a
trustee for 33 years and am now a
trustee emeritus then we established a
similar scholarship at the law school
for assistance on merit to give them an
incentive to come to the law school we
were happy to have this meeting in the
Diana Center which is the new student
center and Barney because the tannest
center represents the continuation of
the efforts of the trustees and the
faculty of this institution to keep it
current functional there was never
really a real theater there's a theater
in this building they had to use the
gymnasium for performances and there are
places to rehearse and there are
classrooms the pleasure for us is in the
doing to see things accomplished because
of what we've been able to help with we
don't need the Wrecking I guess the
ruffian we don't need the recognition we
just do it and enjoy it